[Music]
you
never know who you're going to encounter
in an online match
it could be your garden variety super
angry 12 year olds
or a smurfing pro who's having a bit of
fun
at your expense coming i'm telling you
he's a pro player
look at him go
no problem it might be a big name
streamer
mixing it up with the plebs dude holy
crap let's go baby
oh my god keep your hands up thank you
so much for the host dude
or maybe just maybe it's a former
navy diver who's putting 20 years of
military expertise
into kicking your ass
take eat that [ __ ] one more grandpa
grandpa got them all yes hey that was a
no scope with a triple take
meet grandpa gaming a melon popping
actual boomer who spent about a third of
his life
in the us military and nearly 45
years playing video games what made you
want to play these type of games
because i'm a killer a trained
killer but it's not how long he's been
playing video games that's the
impressive part it's the fact that he's
been through a
laundry list of debilitating health
issues that would have broken a lesser
man
and is still going strong there's two up
there
[Laughter]
that hurt so how did this grizzled vet
end up streaming on twitch and how has
braining fools for a live
audience actually helped him cope with
the real life challenges he faces
every day oh yeah headshot baby
headshot boom nice shot
who's your mama
now if you have never heard of grandpa
gaming
you are really in for a treat he's a 67
year old us vet who likes to cook
and here you are folks lobster stuff
portobello mushroom
bon appetit he loves astronomy this is
grandpa gaming here
what you're looking at right now is
jupiter
and he's occasionally known to sing his
heart out
s pen ass pen everyone needs an ass can
strap it on it'll do you right it'll
save your ass in a fire fight
ass pen but most importantly this
old timer loves to click on heads
down oh got em all
[Music]
that was a beautiful headshot while
gramps
as his community affectionately calls
him may not be as big as some of his
streaming idols
like shroud dr disrespect and ninja
it's impossible to question his
commitment to their very same grind
there's times that i put 100 hours a
week into this
or possibly more i've done a 38-hour
stream
many 24-hour streams you know i'll just
get into it and it seems like it never
ends
oh did you see this but perhaps the most
remarkable thing about gramps's
dedication to his stream
is the fact that he endures so much
just to make it happen you'll see a big
scar
right there that that was from a machete
in the philippines
if i sit in this chair for more than 20
30 minutes
the feeling in my hands is gone
everything from the shoulder down to the
fingertips
i can feel the pressure but it's it's
all numb
and when you do a first-person shooter
on the was and d
key my fingers will roam off and
then problems start and while he has
found a way to keep his hands steady
when playing by using a special glove he
calls
the claw the other chronic health issues
he's faced
haven't been as easy to deal with
constant pain
24 hours a day i'm sleeping or not
i am getting really tired my wrist is
all swollen
so i'm going to call it a night but as
much as streaming takes a lot out of him
for gramps the escapism and social
interaction it provides
more than makes up for it next time
gaming for him is a source of like
coping with pain it's a great coping
tool for
people with ptsd physical pain emotional
pain that type of stuff
now gramps has been gaming since the
good old days of wing commander
but he decided to take a shot at
streaming when a friend
introduced him to twitch in june of
2015.
he said well you should try streaming i
said
what's that he goes you know
on twitch and i said no what is that
the very next night gramps went live for
the first time
and he has not looked back since
did i say you can come in my house you
didn't knock on the door
and while pubg and apex legends were the
games that really kicked off his
channel's early success
unlike a lot of streamers grams has been
able to maintain his audience while
playing a variety of different games
oh right in the head did you see that
oh he's looking at oop
[Laughter]
yeah eat that [ __ ] now just because
gramps likes to get rowdy and talk a
little smack to zoomers
that doesn't mean that his stream's a
total free-for-all
when it comes to the rules of engagement
in his community
he's as strict on others as he is on
himself
in the stream itself there's no politics
no racism no religion at all you
we don't talk about it and that's
because
bitter bitter wars have been started
over
race religion and politics
those are the rules those are the big
rules right there
and if you break them my mods will say
adios muchachos
now just like any other streamer gramps
has to put up with the everyday
[ __ ] of live content creation
whether that comes in the form of
stream snipers or even worse
cheaters
elevator again elevator no no he was
right here
i hit him and he worked away instantly
it's berkeley
you shouldn't have to cheat in a game
period it's
if you don't have the skill don't play
the game and it's all about having fun
and when you're out there busting your
butt especially at my age and with my
handicaps
and then get taken out by a cheater
before you get to number one
i still don't understand and a lot of
people don't
what no way no uh-uh
as long as you're playing fairer though
gramps is happy to have
you around and will help you in any way
he can like the time that he and his
team worked together to get an
eight-year-old his first apex legends
victory
[Music]
this little boy was trying so hard to
get a kill and just kind of
impress you know like he just wanted
that limelight
and it was really tough to watch that
but with gramsci
he just like very very naturally i mean
kind of came in
and let him have his moment and it was
great and honestly it's
heartfelt moments like these that have
earned gramps the respect
and adulation of his viewers one young
man
said that his parents thought that what
he was doing
was a waste of time i said well don't
listen
to that that those are naysayers about
two weeks later he came back
and thanked me because now his parents
are behind him
100 because he actually showed
his parents clips of what i did and
they just jumped on the bandwagon and
now he's he's
happy as can be but as much as the last
couple of years have been
filled with laughter for gramps and his
community
it hasn't all been smooth sailing on top
of the long lasting effects of injuries
he sustained from war
gramps has survived a battle with
prostate cancer
a pulmonary embolism and most recently
in 2018
two heart attacks genuine
life-threatening situations that
worried gramps's audience but only
strengthened his resolve to get back to
them
hopefully i will uh be out of here in
five days
and be able to put some more vids on
youtube
so be safe be honest and game on
but with the support of his loving wife
and his extended family of followers
gramps has pushed past the physical
challenges he faces every day
without fearing the consequences
everyone's going to die sometime
whether i die today or
next year or 50 years from now
it doesn't matter to me it doesn't scare
me in the least
i'm going to do what i'm going to do and
nothing's going to hold me back
and while gramps has been raided by
bigger streamers
and hopes that his stream continues to
grow he remains
dedicated above all else to giving back
to his community a successful stream
would be
any stream to where we had a lot of
laughs
interaction with the chat were they're
asking for advice and i would
i would give them advice on this and
that
these days gramps can still primarily be
found fragging out when he goes live
but he's constantly looking for ways to
connect with his viewers whether that's
in the form of sharing recipes
or his interest in stargazing at the end
of the day
whatever content grandpa gaming chooses
to make
it's really hard not to admire the
passion and commitment that goes into it
his journey is a wholesome beautiful
reminder that there's more to gaming
than just
elo and kdrs it's an outlet for creating
lifelong bonds memories that make us
laugh
on the platform and it's a way to help
us overcome battles in our own lives
battles that not everyone knows we're
fighting and for gramps
if he can bring as many people together
as possible with the time he has
left that's all that matters heart
attacks
be damned it's not just about gaming
it's about
influencing people giving them good
advice
even show in the older generation that
you can still have fun
a golden age or silver age and
cope with life that's what we're all
about
[Laughter]
oh my god i did it
i i i asked one favor make me look
pretty
scandalized by the the language on
stream
yeah guys shooting at you like you said
something bad about his mother
yeah i did called her a [ __ ]
one of the one of the roughest things
i've ever said on camera